I mean I have to consciously
listen to a lot of weird feelings and
luckily have some tools that help me
these days to not be owned by that
feeling yeah and one of the hardest ones
is that oh man Harry Styles's new song
is better than our new song or something
like that right luckily I've been taught
how to very quickly be just inspired by
it like you know what it's awesome and
he's awesome and I love him and I'm just
going to work harder I just saw him at
Coachella last summer and he was dancing
and turned around and I saw that he had
an H on the left butt cheek and an s on
the right butt cheek and I thought
Jesus
that's an innovation I need to steal I
need to walk around outside the O takes
care of itself
I'll get a little apostrophe put over my
okay my anus
um this uh this was really a blast this
we're gonna finish on that I do you
think there's a better place